so earlier today rush limbaugh had some
very wise harsh words for those trying
to block the release of the FISA abuse
memo what's this what's the big deal
with this memo if Trump is guilty
if Trump did all this why are they
worried about a memo detailing how they
did it if Trump did it if Trump colluded
if Trump did all this horrible stuff if
carter page did all this horrible stuff
if Stephen Miller did all his horrid
Melania Trump did all this horrible
stuff if Donald Trump jr. if Eric Trump
that if Barron Trump then well it's hard
for horrible stuff why in the world is
the FBI so afraid of people finding out
how they got it why is the FBI why the
drive-bys why the Democrat Party so
worried so concerned about how they got
there I've gone through as much of this
as I can absorb before it all starts to
turn into a blue purple murky haze and I
can't find any good reasons to not
disclose this memo that's great by the
way when I do radio microphones here how
does he do it from so far away I guess
that's why he's number one I don't know
here are the reaction former Utah
congressman Fox News contributor jason
Chaffetz Judicial Watch president tom
Fitton
okay I think this is what we're gonna
get tomorrow this is why they don't want
it because the phony Clinton bought and
paid for dossier was used in part to get
a FISA warrant it's Russian propaganda
congressman yeah I think we're also
going to start to see the financial
trail who was paying for it how it was
financed who was moving along I'm
worried that it's actually broader than
just the FBI and remember this Peter
struck character this is the chief of
counterespionage he was the assistant
director for counterintelligence he's
using a non-secure phone to send fifty
thousand text messages to his lover who
he's having an affair with and they know
the Russians the Chinese and everybody
and and the Russians that Chinese and
everybody else don't already know about
the American people are gonna be
actually the last ones to hear about it
the
the irony of Hillary paying the Russians
for paying for Russian propaganda in the
end and then that he used to get a
warrant to spy on her opposition
candidate in an election year tom Fitton
you deal with government corruption all
the time everything deal with anything
this big no I've been doing this for
twenty years a traditional watch and you
know I saw the FBI files go over to the
Clinton White House the Chinese generals
go into the White House but never did we
see the powers our government being used
to spy in a political opposition like
this or at least any information that we
had today and you know I know why the
Democrats don't want this to come out
Hillary Clinton helped pay for this her
campaign the Democratic National
Committee also helped pay for this
dossier which was used by the Democratic
administration so you've got the
Democratic Party upset about news or
confirmation that Democratic Party money
went to help the FBI spy on its
political opposition and James Comey who
went to the president directly president
elect Trump directly with this dossier
and threw it in his face in a private
meeting did he tell the president that
they had been paid for by Hillary
Clinton and remembered that precipitated
ultimately in his firing and the
appointment of Muller who by all
accounts is still using this dossier to
target Trump world that's the you know
at the end of the day congressman
Chaffetz that's it that there would be
no Trump
Russia collusion without all of these
events or the fact that at the FBI knew
that this was Hillary Clinton paid for
propaganda and Comey as we understand it
wanted to even hire Christopher Steele
and pay Christopher Steele we'll learn
more about that too and did rod
Rosenstein expand the FISA warrant and
if he did he's the one that appointed
Muller
it seems so corrupt and incestuous to me
at this point how do we possibly make
this right
well only sunlights gonna make it better
only exposing it you know I find it
curious that the FBI
saying please don't release the names
don't release the names we don't want to
disparage all of the FBI we want to
highlight the people that are doing the
wrong and you call them out by name
that's how you get rid of those people
that's how you highlight the wrongdoing
and you make them accountable on this
and it's going to be the Inspector
General that it will come up on the
heels of this and fill in even more well
that's totally gonna give four pages
tomorrow but then the Inspector General
felonies were committed tom Fitton we
have 20 seconds and call me page struck
McCabe and likely Loretta Lynch gave her
a pass so she could stay in the race
true or false well that's what it looks
like and the question is whether the
next steps going to be after this memo
are released are we going to get the
accountability we desire we're going to
find out who did the unmasking who did
the leaking this is just the tip of the
iceberg and just one battle that needs
to be fought for full accountability on
this scandal that's a very important
point tomorrow I'm told this 10% of
what's coming that's scary